and I think the pinky out maybe oh the
pinky out the pinky
out hello
[Music]
hello hey it's Jared Leto from 30
Seconds to Mars and this is snack Wars
the UK versus the US for lab
Bible
ooh wow Co be and toast versus little
mac and cheese maybe Paprika in there
I'm going to have to take the gloves off
of this one is it is that what you call
them beans and toast beans on toast
let's be honest here I don't know what
I'm going to do with a
knife this is how I eat beans and toast
no no I think it's uh what do you do
here yeah I just put it on here right
yeah and I just slurp it down but I
quite like
it mhm
honestly it's one of my favorite things
to eat is beans and toast really yeah
and I forgot about it on this trip and
you just reminded me and a lot of
Americans don't don't get it oh no I
love it it's honestly it's one of my My
Favorite Things is uh beans and toast I
thought I heard someone sleeping a
second
ago the beans take it point for the
beans beans magical
fruit okay here it goes tada Starbucks
pumpkin spice
latte Starbucks pumpkin spice latte I've
never
had oo
Jasmine it's
Jasmine what is it l gray Earl Gray the
classic yeah I have to say the king of
teas Earl Gray nothing starts your day
better than Earl Gray are you supposed
to slurp it or is that something slurp
it and I think the pinky out maybe oh
the pinky out pinky
out I can teach you how to um say hello
with a posh accent please go do you yeah
yes so what is this stuff called uh that
we all
breathe uh okay and what is this stuff
on your
head and what is a lion sleeping not a
den but a l and if you put them all
together
there you
are isn't that great people go crazy for
this I've heard about
this it's like a
dut it's a donut it's very sweet but
it's pretty fun I'm into the classic if
you had to have one for a lifetime
you're going to go with this we got to
say it for the
queen oh sorry let's see what we got oh
hell yeah come on now all right well we
all know what this is this is called uh
crack in a bag this is the gateway drug
to Every Other Drug
Percy Percy the pig oh wow that's really
pigy look at that kind of cute little
scary too right a little bit menacing
I'm going to say yeah that little the
Gran
[Laughter]
is
by the way I have a really strong sense
of taste and
smell I can smell everywhere right
now and what you ate last night not only
this
morning uh it's a curse that's actually
really good it's good right it is really
good because it's it's actually kind of
a complex flavor in there it's not just
that one thing what flavor night is you
getting there's something interesting in
there I can't I yeah it's like
a it's just a sweet little bit of
goodness I don't know it's definitely
not a pig but I mean you're going
head-to-head I don't know who to compare
it to but it's like uh Mayweather of
candy the like Tyson of candy it's it's
hard to mess with this
one I mean it takes a while cuz you know
it sticks to every tooth in your MTH I
got to go with Percy and I'm going to
tell you why you English people are
killing it today this one it says made
with real fruit and this one it says
made with natural
colors if I started a a candy com I
would just say made with everything
unnatural here we go it looks like um
something a little less sweet oh it's
Greg's look at this Greg's
vegan friendly range so I take it this
is
a sausage roll it's a sausage
roll smells like a sausage roll and this
is let me see
ooh ooh that's a mess in there look at
this thing by the way who's going to
take a bite out of this for me
wow yeah I think I'm going to p Cadena
on this one but I would try the Gregs
thing that's cool and maybe you win by
[Music]
default it's actually pretty good yeah
it that's actually really good it is
good yeah man you guys have a lot of fun
food to eat over here and I gotta say
that Gregs you win by default because
there's no way I'm going to take a bite
out of
this
well I mean I'm not too sure about what
is Seabrook bags of flavor made with
pride ooh Worcester shister Sher Shire I
like that I like that oh a chip with
Worcester shister sh I always loved that
sauce it's a bit mysterious but really I
know what's in
[Music]
there that's a lot of flavor
ho wow in a good way I'm a little
confused and a little wor sister s
sister sire is great but Leah and paren
they they must be you know whoever Leah
and parens are or Liam Barons they they
must be billionaires because they've
they've made for sister shash uh for a
thousand years nobody else dares to make
it because who knows what's in that
probably like an old boot some cigarette
butts maybe like some water at the
bottom of a shoe if her a sailor went
out on a 3-day like you know just poured
in now
now Classics right Pringles I don't even
think there's a potato in here anywhere
to be found but the it's a
classic brings back memories but
honestly if if you put a little bit of
salt on a piece of
paper it it might be the same thing see
Brook you you took it you guys what is
that a clean sweep it's a clean sweep
sneaky you did this on purpose you
English people you stack in your
favor I mean what can I say I'm very
proud to be here but one thing I would
suggest is that you give guests um a
toothbrush cuz it's really I don't know
what's happening on my tongue right now
it's it's
bizarre so I'm I'm Jared Le